lose that uh kind of heartbreaking game
to zhuan jun a few moments ago and anish
meanwhile
not in the flow when he's at his best uh
wow
i was just about to say when anish is
his best he can punish anyone but will
he punish richard report because reports
played a really weird
night moved look at that white knight on
the edge of the board what is it doing
there
uh i think this is called the swagginsev
sicilian
i'm not sure on the pronunciation there
yeah it's very rare uh very rare line
named after a very strong russian player
but either way that white knight can be
misplaced in some of these variations in
giri look at gary what's he doing with
his face right now he does not look
amused at all
um yeah he just uh he's not reacted to
the surprise he's just playing his move
uh played instantly as well
so uh right now black needs to get
castled white is the first one to
complete development
and is gary frozen no he's just
continuing to
he'd just not look amused at all
this uh opening idea from rapport it is
very rare we should mention putting a
knight on the edge of the board uh kind
of goes against all wisdom we're taught
uh when we're young and i think giri
he's a traditionalist he's a classicist
he wants to punish opponents when they
do weird wacky things against him
no i mean it's so rare it's actually
never been played before i mean just uh
this position total new ground and uh
that's kind of explains anish's face he
did remind me of um
lauren hardy stan laurel he would always
go
i wonder what's happening there and uh
it is it is actually kind of natural
when you're faced with a surprise and it
is a little bit orthodox
because rapport has kind of played this
knight moved to the edge of the board
but he hasn't backed it up by the
usual's plans instead he's kind of
relocated his pieces to unorthodox
squares and it becomes like how am i
going to make sense of what white is
doing yeah how is he going to make sense
of that knight he decides nope he's not
going to keep it on the edge of the
board any longer he's going to try and
re-centralize it but
this knight could have maybe found a
better square a more active square
if it hadn't gone to the side of the
board in the first place so definitely
don't follow this one too much at home
but richard rapport he's a creative
genius he needs to get those juices
flowing
and this i think is the way that he
tries to motivate himself
he loves to play weird stuff get out of
the opening and uh by surprising his
opponents with small little ideas here
and there i think that's how he often
gets his victories he normally makes
them think or normally kind of
provokes them into a mistake and look at
what he's doing putting all these pawns
on light squares it's as if he wants to
trap his own light squared bishop uh
rapport and the evaluation bar not keen
on this last move it does look very
counter-intuitive it must be said
yeah i mean i almost feel that that pawn
and porn move is like breaking the rules
and we're kind of taught gotta be
respectful about your squares don't give
your opponent any squat any squares to
kind of take control of and uh look at
uh richard's position it's kind of full
of holes on the dark squares yeah it's
like that type of cheese what do you
call it with all the holes in it
yeah that one
we have jarlsberg you know
yeah and uh yeah it's it's as if the
cheese is the white the light squares
where all white pawns are and the holes
are the dark squares in between all
those white pawns
and uh yeah i mean we call this the
botvinic structure with white structure
in the center um those pawns and light
squares but
yeah it can backfire if if you don't get
the right pawn breaks later the right
activity
if black for example construct can
strike and open up the position white
will regret it
well nishkiri he is coming from a win
against timor or jabot that would have
been a win either way because timor has
pulled out of the tournament he is
feeling sick that's why you're not
seeing a bar in his game
against jeffrey chung that is a walk
over victory for jeffrey and it will be
for all the players so all praise will
gain uh three points against timor and
of course we're sending um feel better
wishes for timor feeling sick
unfortunately and he is out of the
tournament one of the favorites so that
is a shame
you know i think i picked him as my
favorite for the tournament seriously
i'm not regretting that one oh you get
to pick a new one
jeffrey
i fancy that
but yeah i mean uh yeah a lot of warm
wishes to timor absolutely yeah
for getting better yeah yeah
and okay meanwhile the first on passant
that i've seen today and maybe even in
this tournament uh black's pawn moved
two squares the black b pawn but white
captured it as if it just moved one
square
and suddenly change in pawn structure
means that actually white's pawn
structure that we were kind of really a
bit critical of there the cheesy pawn
structure is superior to black structure
because black is the one with the
isolated pawn if you look on the a file
that black a6 pawn has no mates uh no
other
pawns around it and long term may be an
issue there for anishikiri giri does
have the bishop pair however so if the
position if the center especially opens
up
then black will be in charge richard uh
richard's idea here is just keep it
locked down
those two white knights actually
combined quite well
so i was critical earlier but uh richard
he did weird stuff and now he's kind of
trying to make amends for all those
rules he broke yeah
that's his trademark right you know he
does incredibly bizarre things at the
opening but then in the middle game
totally normal position maybe he has a
little bit of a pull
and uh yeah
back to normal back to business and i
have to say i really do like richard's
position for niche it's not easy to find
a plan i mean the first move that kind
of came to mind was actually to lengthen
the diagonal of the dark square bishop
and you see that on them on the board
but beside that
that's it i mean there's no pawn break
so to speak of unless unless i spoke to
you soon unless you're kind of being
really really aggressive and
going to start challenging why it's a
pawn structure there on the center yeah
white strong pawn center the bob vinick
structure named after mikhail bovinick
russian world champion
yeah it's very very strong at the moment
that center it really blocks out this
bishop especially which is staring at
this kind of concrete
statue right now on e4 so undermining it
would make a lot of sense and ivanka you
mentioned no real pawn breaks apart from
this so maybe it's
black's only real plan uh to try and
undermine the stronger hold in the
center if you can open things up for
example if white
just makes a move actually this move
maybe prevents uh this pawn move so uh
let's say white just plays a slow move
here then suddenly black's bishops look
fantastic along these two diagonals the
two longest diagonals in chess
and actually this is possible right now
black's rook also becomes pretty active
black's knight can jump into the center
of the board
black's queen could slide back line up
with her bishop on this diagonal um so
this would be ideal for andy shkiri if
he can make it happen and the question
is after this last move that's played in
the game white's rook stepping forward
one square
oh i was gonna say is anish gonna seize
the moment and push his pawn try and
open things up go for glory
no he's just playing a passive rook move
and the evaluation bar not liking this
maybe that was the one moment he had
and now because this rook went to a
passive square not really clear what
it's doing there
rapport is the first one to push and
look at these white pawns suddenly
they're dominant white maybe trying to
go forward on the attack and anish giri
saying okay this pawn push is maybe
on your mind so i'm going to try and
slow it down
black's pawns now just really solid
they're going to react to whatever white
does
it's as if both sides are saying okay
you come to me first i don't want to
make the first move
i don't think report should be pushing
pawns forward anymore if the heavy does
push forward if the thing if the
position just becomes open then the
bishops are the pieces of the prophet
and uh basically white has done black's
dirty work for him so yeah don't want to
be doing that um but then this begs the
question what is richard's plan
if he's not gonna go forward
i mean i'm just looking at that tangle
of pieces on the left
i mean they don't have a purpose
that's true especially this bishop right
now i was gonna say it needs to be
improved it's not clear which square i
was going to say maybe use this square
just uh stare down at the black queen
along this diagonal but instead he
defends his knight
he moves his bishop
sorry in this position after black
pushed upon he defends his knight
yeah you're right ivanka it's a bit of a
tangle these pieces maybe at some point
he wants to relocate this knight wants
to centralize it maybe eventually at
some point he'll swing his queen across
go for this weak pawn this isolated pawn
it's unclear at the moment but uh very
much both sides just treading around
and uh waiting for the others to make
that move
and i just want to mention one thing
clock is now
local in iceland 509
and exactly 50 years ago right at this
minute bobby fischer walked in for the
first game he came nine minutes late and
it's exactly 50 years ago right there's
with it oh
i get goosebumps isn't that strange i
always feel it they had their handshake
the world championship match officially
started this time 50 years ago yeah
first move was played yeah yeah i saw
some of that footage you know where
spassky was waiting for fischer to turn
up and everyone was like will he turn up
will he come to the board and he has
like supernatural tension and then he
just kind of casually came in
a blank traffic jam i think yeah
[Laughter]
yeah this minute 50 years ago the 1972
world chess championship match started
with a disaster for bobby fischer in the
first game a huge blunder and after this
game david is going to teach us all
about that game we're going to go
through it in detail it's going to be
fun yeah huge blunder in that game
actually it was headed towards a draw
everyone thought ah a draw that's a good
way to start a world championship it's
fair it's both players will be happy but
one moment of madness
cost across bobby that game wow
yeah arriving late never a good start
exactly
all right well these two players richard
report he played and the candidates
aneesh shagiri didn't make it to
the candidates he really hoped to to
make it but he didn't but richard
reported he ended last place and the
candidates he didn't have a good
tournament
but here he is against anish geary what
do you think about this game will it be
a winner will it be a draw what does it
look like i'm hoping there's enough
imbalance in the position that we will
see a winner it's not clear who that
winner will be but
despite the fact that queens are off now
despite the fact we're heading towards
an endgame i can't see this one being
drawn anytime soon there are enough
imbalances as we mentioned black has
this weak a pawn black's bishop pair
however do look pretty good right now
and uh there's a lot of life left in
this position the one thing i want to
say about rapport as well is that in the
candidates yes he struggled but
the games he lost rapport it's because
he was trying to play normal chess and
that's not him every time he played
normal chess it seemed to backfire every
time he played a bit weird um he got
decent positions and this game he's
definitely been trying to do weird stuff
so that's a good sign for him i think uh
in this one anishigiri
i think he's reacted pretty well in
general to the surprises the evaluation
bars on black's side he's got a lot of
time left on the clock gary but
it's just about who kind of feels this
position now the queens are off who
feels it better who can put their piece
on better squares who can create the
first threats yeah and i think we i'm
talking about richard reporting the
candidates i think we have
some footage of richard report playing
the candidate so on the chessboard he
didn't to to do too well but uh when it
came to his style i would say he's a
definite winner he came every day with
like a new fresh suit different colors
he seemed look at that how cool is that
it's very cool i don't know red is the
color of champions
and uh
a new outfit as well yeah even better
very stylish is he known for that
richard report to be one of the you know
into how he looks and clothing and you
know dressing stylish
yeah i guess so yeah um i have never
really noticed it that much until
recently i've got to say live on ironian
previously had that kind of uh that
title that mantle of being the best
dressed or at least the most
flamboyantly dressed but uh yeah report
now
i love the pictures as well with the
sunglasses just rocking up reservoir
dogs just
dress for success exactly a bit of a
rockstar in a way
and one of the things about richard's
style is that he does capture the hearts
and imaginations of everyone watching
because it's so it's so maverick and
it's so unique to him that you know we
we love this type of chess player and we
love this creativity and uh this on you
know just quirkiness yeah and uh yeah
he's he has a big
fan base out there and he actually he's
uh changed federations lately as well
from um hungary where he's from to
romania is it that's right so uh it's i
think
that's
going under process at the moment uh
it's not official but uh he will be
changing his federation at some point i
think he's had issues with the hungarian
chess federation in the past some
disputes there some disagreements and
i know he and his wife who's from serbia
they've spent a lot of time in romania
in the past they've played tournaments
there and i think he feels he'll get
more support from a new federation
for his career so
it makes sense i guess and uh i'm not
sure where exactly he's living right now
i know he was living in the serbia in
belgrade for a long long time
but uh either way maybe that switch of
federation would just take a burden off
his mind maybe if he does get some more
uh some more support
he's tended to work mostly alone uh for
a long time occasionally working with
others but
if he does maybe build a team around him
do all the right things like napolnia
she's doing for example then
yeah i could definitely see him coming
back getting back into the candidates
one day giving it a better shot
he's one of the most talented players
out there that's for sure yeah
yeah certainly a champion and it's a
special day of chess and it's also of
course a special day because we're
celebrating bobby fischer versus boris
spassky match of the century 50 years
since that happened and we are asking
for our quiz of the day who do you hold
as the biggest champion in chess history
and abhishek says that the biggest
champion in chess history for them has
to be vichy anand his match against
topalov in 2008 in sophia in a hostile
environment was a classic the volcano
the long road travel and the no draws
chest made up for a nerve-wracking match
also went on to win the last game yeah
yeah that one was very very tense match
and uh mike d says uh
he doesn't he doesn't have an answer to
our quiz of the day but
just has a comment just wants to share
with us yeah his uh seven-year-old son
decided to make a chess board in
minecraft oh you do we designed the
pieces together
and uh i like it when the when the
viewers and the audience just well they
tweet us their selfies their pictures of
all the unusual chess things that
they're doing and of course we do have
our quiz of the day
you can answer that by tweeting us using
the hashtag chess champs and remember
great prize up for grabs absolutely and
talking about that great
virtual
chess set remember that in every
tournament we do have an nft
giveaway so you can you can actually
collect chess pieces different chess
pieces in every tournament
and actually this tournament it's a
mystery chess piece but that must mean
it is a cool chess piece so just head
into chesschamps.io
giveaways and you can claim your free
mystery chess piece that at some point
you can actually use in
in a game i think i mean
very cool nfts it's the future you guys
it is the future and you can use it in a
game yeah oh
it's free
what's not to love
exactly
um and we do have the porn move that we
highlighted quite a few moves ago
finally on the board
well anish wants to do one thing and one
thing only he wants to blast away break
down white's blockade on the light
squares
yeah he wants to open lines up for the
black bishops makes a lot of sense and
one thing that isn't free
in this position at least is the black
pawn on a6 and this board looks like
it's up for grabs but if white takes it
then he has to do a lot of calculation
because suddenly after a rook trade
black's rook can pounce this pawn is no
longer protected
and uh black encounter attack ignoring
his own bishop he can counter attack
against white's bishop and here we might
see a whole massive exchanges uh we
would see rook takes bishop rook takes
bishop but the key here is that at the
very end black is attacking this white
knight black's rook also extremely
active and uh whoa instead we've seen
maybe a strange decision from rapport uh
after black did indeed push this pawn
and try to explode open the position
reports just said yeah you do what you
want i'm going to let you do it and
after a porn exchange suddenly black has
a reverse bathtub structure we call this
the bathtub but it's reversed it's kind
of upside down and uh here white just
said okay i'm gonna ignore you
move the king white's king may be coming
towards the center to protect this
bishop as we mentioned that bishop was
under fire
in some positions and anish giri just
steps back now with his bishop to
protect this pawn just in case i'm not
sure it was actually threatened but why
not protect it it is black's only
weakness in the position and now
i think his plan is to just improve the
black king improve the black rooks and
here we go the kings are both
centralizing at some point maybe black
will switch the focus of the attack over
to the other semi-open file down towards
white pawn over here black might even
use his other isolated pawn as what we
call a minority attack throwing it down
the board later
i just love black's bishops if you look
at the two most important pieces in the
position it's these two they both rake
down on the diagonals and that's why
rapport has retreated his knight next
move for example in black pushes a pawn
rapport wants to challenge black's
strong dark squared bishop
yeah
well clever move from richard there
because i didn't understand the point of
it actually until you pointed out maybe
he's heading in this direction as well
yeah
but uh it does look like anish is the
one with all the potential and i just
love this idea of just using harry the h
born as a as a way to kind of crowbar
open a line uh it's just fantastic
yeah it just looks like black's position
is full of potential i'm not sure how
big his advantage is the computer gives
plus one already for black despite the
fact it's level material but uh either
way it's definitely black with all the
fun and it's because he has uh more kind
of flexible okay here we go the h pawn
does push down the board i was just
saying hypothetically later but he plays
it now but yeah it's just the potential
look at these central pawns you can push
them forward at any moment look at these
bishops they're just fantastic
and
yeah it's just i think it's all about
white trying to neutralize
black at this point rapport has no
dreams of doing anything active
well i say that and then he tries to get
active with his knight maybe but uh yeah
it's definitely white on the back foot
black is the one with all the hope
i i must admit i thought anisha's uh
maybe a little bit too committal with
his uh by pushing the age pawn but uh
okay we will see the players are in full
focus mode and uh richard has to find a
role for his knights at the same time
probably trade off the dark squad bishop
and of course keep an eye on black city
activity three things to do not easy and
a niche switching focus
and now the heat is going to be on the
right side of the board and the one
piece that anish doesn't have really
working that could be improved is the
knight yeah no it's not doing anything
and in dreamland i would plonk it in the
middle of the board and give a check to
the white king
so i wonder whether the light will find
its way there yeah to the d4 square uh
yeah if you can get there it takes a few
moves but if black
uh maybe just when you when
it comes to planning when you're
thinking long term you just imagine a
dream square for your pieces the
knight's ideal square might be one
square and then you just track a route
for that night and this position is a
bit of a slow maneuvering position so
you do have that luxury of two or three
moves here or there to just improve
pieces so white's knight is looking
towards the black king it wants to jump
forward and maybe check the black king
over the next few moves will guri stop
that is that even a scary threat i'm not
so sure but
then gary will be thinking okay improve
the black knight improve the black
brooks
i just love the fact that he's switching
the focus of the play anishikiri over to
this side of the board now that the
white rooks are actually distracted on
the other flank so that's very uh kind
of typical strategy if your opponents
focus too much on one area if they're
not actually threatening anything switch
the focus to the other half of the board
and uh gary has stopped the white knight
on this edge of the board from uh
jumping in to the black half yeah
and uh big big issues right he has to
use one of his rooks to defend it's uh
well it's a kind of needs must move
unpleasant
but it had to be done
very passive square ugly square for the
white rook
but uh yeah he's at least saying to giri
you have to break through you have to
find uh something
special now you have to find another
gear of your attack
i mean i'm looking at the black knight
but i'm also looking at that black rook
in the corner maybe black can lift one
of his rooks on the g file and then
swing the other rook across to kind of
back it up if you could double up your
rooks on the same line that's even more
powerful
that makes a lot of sense one plan at
least yeah
so anisha in a very comfortable
situation
um well when we take a look at the clock
situation we see that anish has just run
under six minutes meanwhile richard
does have a time advantage he's only
just under 11.
what
what is white doing though with all his
knights on the edge of the board he put
a knight on the edge of the board on
move two now he's stuck with a knight on
the other edge of the board and
just breaking all the rules richard
yeah this is not the type of game to
show your students to show someone who's
learning uh the rules of chess just
breaking
yeah down all these barriers but yeah
it's not working so far it could be a
cautionary tale you show this to your
students this is what happens when you
break the rules if he loses then it will
be instructive if he somehow
miraculously wins as white then yeah
definitely don't show this to the young
young students of the game i mean
when you look at the clocks he's got a
huge advantage he i mean 26 moves and
richard is
more than 10 minutes on the clock should
he play a little bit slower
possibly i think he's banking on the
fact that later giri will be low on time
maybe giri will make a mistake in time
pressure
but you can't guarantee at the top level
that anyone will make a mistake giri is
phenomenally strong and uh giri's used
to playing low on time as we saw
yesterday giri had this
lost position against aronian he had 30
seconds down two pawns but he still held
the draw
so uh giri can be quick when he needs to
be
reports uh he's just saved up that time
for later but remember report he lost to
juwen june in the last round he still
had seven and a half minutes when he
lost that game
so maybe it's best to invest that time a
bit earlier yeah do you think this is
tiredness because obviously he's just
played the candidates on top of that he
also played the bundesliga this weekend
oh yeah so uh and now we see him playing
another high intensity tournament
and one of the most busy minute chess
yeah yeah
i think he's his schedule was incredibly
packed he'd accidentally said yes to all
these tournaments
something yesterday he had to pull out
last minute because it was just too much
he just didn't think that he was going
to qualify for the candidates and then
he finds himself you know oops look at
my schedule chuckle block as we say and
that's actually a common uh kind of
it's something we see a lot basically uh
when players are tired they actually
play quicker because they just don't
have energy to sit there and calculate
they don't have the patience and i've
been there myself when i'm when i
haven't slept well i'll play a bit
quicker just because i just want to get
it over with i just want to get back to
bed and sleep
maybe that's what rapport's doing right
now yeah yeah and here we go black
uh with this last move alicia he's moved
his rook down but the other rook is
ready to swing across
and join its fellow on the g file this
looks beautiful for giri
okay rapport lashes out he needed to do
something before it's too late
and he tries to open the position this
pawn can be captured in two ways it can
be captured with the black f-pawn or on
passant with this age pawn
and okay at least he's trying to get
stuff off the board he's trying to just
hoover off pieces he's hoping that the
trades will guide him to safety yeah
but he it's a really passive approach
that he's employing you know he's just
hoping to
huddle up in the center on the second
row with his knights and then just
survive
um
sometimes you have to do these things
but it's never very pleasant
especially with white groveling for a
draw
on the back foot the whole game it's not
ideal and having more time on the clock
you have extra time to suffer or
if you actually i never advocate being a
pessimist when you're playing chess you
need to be positive yeah
and especially when you're defending you
just have to think about that one chance
that one little hope that you have and
take it on a move by moved basis so
whilst you keep surviving you know your
hopes uh just remain alive
but uh you've interviewed richard i mean
both of you have interviewed richard
rapport he's famous for his pessimism
right that's right yeah that's true
actually yeah the way he talks about
chess you know he hates the game he
hates his life hates everything but
i can tell you he actually loves it he
enjoys uh the creativity yeah
i think i think it's a little bit
he he kind of likes to give that
impression because i'm sure when he's
playing at the board he's not thinking
oh my goodness me what am i doing my
position is rubbish i have to play this
i'm like
playing the candidates one minute and
now i'm playing this kind of position
i'm sure he's just not thinking that i'm
so i think i'm sure he's
thinking about the chances he has yeah i
remember i asked him so what'd you
expect from yourself in online rapid
chess and he said well
i think i'm better at classical chess
but i'm not very good at classical chess
he's only like number seven exactly
i grilled him a little bit and did it
over dinner and nowhere chasse was like
really really and he laughed a little
bit i was like
yeah you've got to call him out on his
statements yeah it's bluffs
because i was asking him like you know
because he also gives the impression
that you know he's freestyling his
openings of like how much work are you
putting into your openings and he was
like oh not that much no no i'm just
literally just making i'm like really
he goes
[Laughter]
well i'm looking at uh four
rooks on the same line yes that's
interesting standoff time and often i
think you've called the right moment to
mention that kaya because all the four
rooks might just disappear on this next
move uh we could see white's rook the
the front rook that is attacked right
now by black's bishop by blackstroke
it i mean it has no safe squares it
could just go and exchange itself off
and all the rooks will just disappear
i'm trying to look for other options
reports looking for other options but i
can't see a way to keep all the rooks on
the board and giri's trying to force the
exchange of the rooks because he's
gambiting on the fact that
the more pieces that disappear will
favor his bishop pair black's two
bishops clearly superior to white's
knights at the moment so
yeah we will see a transition
transformation into a proper end game
now
and who will that favor i think black
it has to be black
i mean like but the question is
like you say you know will white manage
to kind of curl up in a ball and just
defend all those entry points
yeah
i guess white doesn't have too many
attackable weaknesses white has some
weaknesses but black's pieces aren't
ready to attack them imagining this
exact position but all the rooks
disappearing
it's still hard for black to make
progress to actually achieve something
next
but uh what else is report looking at is
he thinking of jumping in with the white
knight to give a check right now to the
black king
maybe that's an option but that's very
risky
uh that could well just backfire
but that's the type of player he is
rapport he's
he's sent something he's saved his time
he's got so much time but he's saved it
all for now
to try and calculate
yeah i'm a bit puzzled actually as to
why he's thinking because
exchanging off rooks looks the most
natural move to me but
do you really want to change the dynamic
of the position by
maybe maybe it's rich's style actually
you know he has a huge time advantage as
you mentioned and i forgot that anish
has under three minutes
and
in full focus mode yeah does he want to
change the nature of the game that's the
question and let's just try and jump in
and figure out what he's considering
because
the rook is attacked simply why not just
exchange rooks trade one set of rooks
trade a second pair of rooks and say
okay white is solid here it's passive
you're only playing for a draw but at
least maybe you can reroute this knight
i want to put it on this square kick
away the black bishop
maybe black's just got an advantage and
richard doesn't want to sit here and
suffer forever so with that in mind what
else could he do is he going to jump in
with his knight give check but then the
problem is after bishop takes for
example if you take back with the pawn
you have to consider the fact that black
is going to push forward this is a
double attack it's a bit scary
yes you could pin this pawn you could
move your rook across pin the pawn
against the black king but the pawn will
just be backed up by its uh fellow here
and suddenly this black pawn chain is
extremely strong still threats against
white porn here for example
this looks terrible for white to be
honest uh so what else is he considering
this rook is attacked he has to trade it
off
maybe he could consider trading one set
and then jumping in with the white
knight but similar problems will persist
after a trade here and maybe the black
pawn stepping forward yeah well a set of
brooks have left the board okay so uh we
do have some progress and once again
there is a pause i mean
he must be considering that check it's
night jump yeah maybe his idea is quite
concrete if the knight jumps in i'm
trying to calculate on the fly here but
takes uh if white recaptures for example
if black steps forward maybe he can get
active with the white knight and try to
jump in with a check it looks a bit odd
the whole uh kind of justification for
this okay he's traded a set of rooks i
was going to say the justification after
a rook capture is that you can jump in
with a check and there are all sorts of
night jumps here and i think white holds
the balance but if we jump back to the
game there have been some moves all the
rooks did depart from the board and now
white's bishop has gone on a journey it
wants to step into this square and start
attacking black's pawns from behind
so a change of angle here he's trying to
go behind with his pieces which you can
do once the major pieces the queens and
rooks have left the board it's easier to
infiltrate into your opponent's half
into your opponent's camp
and this is a weakness but this pawn can
be defended by black's bishop if it
needs
if it needs to retreat so for example if
black say steps back with the bishop now
what is white's bishop actually doing
that is the question what are white's
knights doing that's the bigger question
well three games have uh finished sevion
he got three points against fellow
american hans niemann levon aronian
three important points for him against
the norwegian arianthari and wei yi a
win for him against chakriyad and
momodyarov and also team rajabov and
jeffrey showing that the game has not
been played because team rajabov has
pulled out due to sickness of the
tournament so uh jeffrey will get three
points in that game all players will
get walk over wins against team rajabov
also uh the five players who already met
him but actually timor had lost four of
those games it was only shakira and
mamdaro played a draw against his fellow
azerbaijani so
mom yaro is the only one who actually
kind of gains point from uh timor rajab
pulling out
two more points for mamadiaro but yeah
so far a lot of decided games this round
this one you think yeah that will be
decided as well probably i guess in
anisha's favor
yes that's the way it's looking at the
moment but anish does have the clock to
contend with uh one and a half minutes
it's maybe not the most
it's not ideal at least when you're
trying to convert a tiny advantage like
he is here
but he's at least improving the black
knight black's knight now has some
squares to jump into maybe
i love anisha's position to be honest i
love bishop pairs first of all but i
love also
these types of pawn structures where
it's all really nice and huddled
together you're really flexible as black
big question though white's night now
attacking black's e6 pawns so this
knight finally has a purpose
finally off the edge of the board
yeah
the thing is that black's position is so
solid especially that pawn structure in
the middle it's so compact and anish
just steps back with his bishop coolly
defends everything and
just for the time being his pieces are
not actively placed but it is just
temporary because now anish is going to
be looking at ways to regroup and
advance his pawns
yeah and he needs to advance the pawns
eventually but it's just finding the
right moment and um recently i've
been studying a lot of grindy type of
positions grinding out these positions
in the end game and that's this type of
position it's not going to be quick it's
not going to be easy but just looking
for these small advantages here and
there abiding your time not making the
same mistake that levon aronian made
yesterday against anishigiri of rushing
pushing your pawns forward
too quickly prematurely you need to find
and pick the right moments and that's
what anish is normally quite good at
doing he's very much a grinder at heart
he likes picking these small advantages
like the bishop hair like the better
pawn structure that he's got right now
and later long term he'll try and
convert that into something bigger or
transform that advantage into maybe
winning a pawn or maybe creating a
passport into something a bit more
direct but right now the black king's
just stepping back i have a feeling the
black king wants to kind of switch over
to go and attack this white bishop kick
the white bishop out of the black half
meanwhile white is dancing with his
knights not sure where that knight is
going
but uh he loves putting knights on the
edge of the board rapport
the third time right third time and
knight has found herself on the edge
that's a slightly unusual i have to say
um okay
but still
white's position is quite solid black's
position is also very compact
um it's always it's always like plan by
plan right i can i kind of coined this
phrase when i can look at these endings
it's like the mini plan
you don't need to look at it so much by
moves you just look about
what are the targets
what are the pieces to improve and
and uh here from for me it would be the
black knight yeah look at that on the
edge as well
also on the edge of the board both
knights are at least on outposts they
can't get kicked away by porn meanwhile
gary down to 20 seconds
so he needs to speed up you mentioned
mini plans he's struggling to formulate
a plan right now gary he's trying to
find a way to improve the black position
but it's not easy you have to look for
tiny moves uh tiny kind of
two three move plans
when in doubt just move a king don't
commit just move a bishop improve a
piece evaluation bar really really
doesn't like that one though
the only thing that might uh justify the
evaluation bar going in white's favor is
one of the knights jumping forward to
start attacking some pawns but
i'm struggling to believe that white can
be better in this position black's
pieces are just
covering every square and uh report will
he switch to a mode where he's no longer
on the defensive will he suddenly get
ambitious report try and cause some
problems for gary because 20 seconds is
not a lot and there's still chances for
the momentum to change white does have
some pawn pushers where i can push a
pawn in the center or i can jump around
with the knights a bit
it's not a hundred percent uh out of the
danger zone for black at the moment yeah
and uh he does
yeah the knights do jump we saw a couple
of very quick moves there now black's
king stepping forward so black is still
protecting everything with his bishops
and i do wonder
in light of anish's time situation that
he should
maybe he's kind of prepare some for some
action although this could be this is a
very risky strategy because maybe the
action is not great
and it's a little bit uh
too courageous and doing black's job for
him but you know anish does only have 35
seconds left on the clock yeah yeah
i mean if rapport wants to gamble and
take a chance which is actually very
much his style then
it feels like now might be the moment
while gary is unsure about what's
happening while gary's low on the clock
while he still has uh a bit of time and
look at reports suddenly he looks a lot
more interested in his position than he
did previously previously he was just
like thinking oh i've got to make some
moves it's not ideal
there he looked focused suddenly he
leaned back he's like oh maybe there's
nothing here after all what kind of move
are we looking for then to see if
richard is going for the kill in this
game maybe a pawn push
um ifanka mentioned you could be pushing
some pawns maybe white central pawn the
white deported step forward one square
but that would be extremely risky okay
he gives a check with his knight forcing
the black king back yeah
and uh if the black king steps to the
wrong square then
there could be kind of like some
switchback with the dark squared bishop
yeah and actually we should mention this
the second time now we've seen this
position and
geary made a move we've seen this before
he made a move without using his hands
we've seen it before in uh previous
events yeah it only ever seems to be
gory actually
uh maybe there was a slight lag a slight
delay there primo
it definitely wasn't a pre-move
you couldn't pre-move a night retreat
like that just in case your opponent had
captured something and you needed to
take back it wasn't a safe pre-move as
we call it
so uh very strange that is the stranger
using it
great air quality we have to say air
things is monitoring the air where niche
gear is sitting it's great his air
quality so maybe his mind can do
just insane things
moving without touching the mouse for
example magicians yeah
it would be nice to see in an action
right because in the oslo esports we
could see them there
with the camera over their hand and the
mouse
it would be nice to kind of
see how maybe he's just like a super
natural
playing at a supernatural speed
you know maybe one of his sons is just
there
he's just saying okay knight f6 and then
his son is like yes daddy i'll move the
bus
but uh it's so strange strange stuff
yeah yeah
well the position just repeating in a
way black's king going back and forth
white's bishop retreating white's
knight's just doing a dance but the
status quo has been maintained it
definitely has i have to say i do like
richard's last move primarily because i
thought about it and i suggested it but
i mean i mean that the whole goal is uh
just to relocate the bishop to a longer
diagonal and also maybe introduce the
idea that it might be possible to
challenge the pawn standing on c5 by
playing b4 yeah so if rapport wants to
win this game then he will have to push
this pawn forward to challenge this porn
as you mentioned ivanka or maybe at some
point push in the center to challenge
this pawn just to change the structure
because at the moment it's a bit blocked
and this uh
backwards kind of
bathtub structure that i mentioned it's
just covers all the squares for black so
you need to remove one of these pawns
somehow if you want to win and talking
of changing the pawn structure geary is
the one trying to win he's pushed this
pawn forward now
we said he had the advantage the whole
time but 20 seconds is a
it's a big gamble to make with only 20
seconds on the clock he's hoping that he
can undermine white's pawn here and the
whole reason is now after capture this
pawn is not up for grabs it's poisoned
if you move your knight away and capture
this pawn then you lose protection of
your other knight and black's king wins
the piece so uh these nights we call
them superfluous nights they actually
get in each other's way they protect
each other but they're stuck uh they're
glued to their squares holding on to
each other and uh maybe gary's found a
good moment he's threatening pawn takes
porn right now winning a pawn if white
just moves then uh pawn takes porn would
win because suddenly a knight check
would force the white king back and
black again wins a piece white's knights
now are big big targets
has the momentum changed again is geary
back in the driver's seat it looks that
way it certainly does and uh
i have to ask the the knights sitting
there on the g5 square it doesn't
actually have a square yeah no retreat
squares and uh that causes problems
actually so i guess
you are forced to go down one route you
know you have to support that poor that
night
nothing for it how i'm struggling to
even see a move to be honest for white
here
i think rapport's struggling as well
he's trying to disappear into his uh
computer screen right now
um
moving the bishop doesn't work for white
you could rule out that
it just looks uh like any bishop moves
are
not really contributing to the battle
the battle switched all uh onto the king
side where the knights are and okay he
exchanges one set of pawns and now he
drops back so maybe this is clever he's
now targeting black's central board the
e5 pawn
and the whites uh the white tonight
oh white tonight sorry um they are at
the moment surviving clinging on and
giri i think he's panicking slightly
retreating his knight there
that's an okay move but it does allow
white's knight the the uh more advanced
white knight at least jump into the
black camp if it needs to or we could
see harry the edge board step up one
square to support its knight the two
knights
that is the only way white will lose the
game now by uh dropping one of those two
nights yeah i must admit if i were in
richard's shoes i would just jump
forward with the night
and get it get it out of trouble
it is
a bit too stressful to have a night
saddled there honda virgil being trapped
and no he goes for the alternative which
is just to push harry forward support
the knight
um
a logical move but at the same time
carries a degree of risk yeah this is
maybe the safe option but as you
mentioned the risk uh that would involve
black's king actually walking to the
edge of the board and white's h-pod is a
target so watch out for that one
happening a bit later
whoa okay a couple of very quick moves
there i was just trying to hold back a
sneeze and
meanwhile yeah what has happened because
i was going to say what black's king
wanted to march forward anyway towards
the yh pawn richard rapport just gave up
that pawn for free he just said okay
check have my pawn and the white knight
has jumped in this is a check hitting
the white king and
the whole point of this by rapport is he
wants to win black central pawn the e5
pawn is attacked three times
can giri save
it big question here do you think you
could save it if i got black support up
temporarily don't see a way
i'm afraid um the white king has to step
back and then
nope i mean the light square bishop
can't come to the aid of the pawn in the
middle and the black king is stuck there
on the on the rim yeah black's king is
actually temporarily on a very bad
square
and giri gave back his pawn he advanced
to pawn bishops have left the board oh i
really don't like this transition for a
report look at black's a port now
black's a pawn could start running down
the board what's to stop it nothing
get going
yeah get going stop pushing yeah 15
seconds in each and you have a pawn yeah
push it
easy plan okay he doesn't go for it yet
he's maybe trying to keep that up his
sleeve for later also knights are
notoriously bad at stopping corner pawns
these rooks pawns like black's airborne
right now because knights can only stop
it from one side
tonight's uh because they are
short-range pieces
they want two sides to stop uh one born
so for example a central pawn they can
stop from anywhere but quarter pawns
they're very bad
against so
yeah giri
the only one who can win this game for
sure but he is running out of pawns so
if rapport can eliminate all the
remaining pawns it will be a draw yeah
it certainly will um but you know what a
task richard has ahead of him and uh
okay he's relocating the night
well you got i guess uh now is the time
for anish to step forward with the king
just
protect over protect the f pawn and at
the same time keep in the pocket the
fact that the black pawn on a6 is going
to push forward
yeah and uh if we count the past pawns
here black has two past pawns the black
a pawn as we've mentioned it's going to
start running very shortly
but also the black f pawn
that has no pawns in front of it to stop
it
and uh in return white does have one
pass born of his own the e4
pawn and yeah those two doubled
on the c file those are very weak those
will drop at some point report it's all
about fighting for the draw here for him
the dream scenario is giving up one of
his white knights for two of black's
remaining pawns ideally he wants to swap
off at one set of knights and if you
note black's a pawn it promotes on a
dark square so if white's king can run
across and hide in that corner later on
then it doesn't matter what else happens
he can even give up the white knights
yeah we'll show that maybe it will
happen later but first he's going after
some of those black pawns and now anish
has uh 20 seconds to calculate whether
he should get greedy and grab a pawn
it would just involve being a trade but
at the same time it looks so good
yeah it's very tempting right now black
can there we go he goes to grab a pawn
he takes it with his bishop rapport
looked a bit surprised there
and
the question is does white use his
knight and go back to capture pawn does
he trade off a set of pieces first
either way it just feels like that black
pawn the a6 pawn it's like an ace up his
sleeve he's going to save it for the
right moment and start pushing it when
white is least ready for it
yeah to be honest i'm not so sure about
this exchange why did black give up one
of his own points for one of white's
doubled pawns he could have kept his
pawn intact
but
black is still the only one who can win
now he's dancing around with this
knights report
and
there's is there some threats on the
board like the knight coming in to give
a check to the black king
and
the problem is you're facing nights and
you only have 10 seconds on the clock
for gary
nights are so tricky to deal with
there's going to be all sorts of night
forks that he has to avoid okay that's a
good idea step your pieces as far away
from your own king as possible meaning
you're not within checking distance so
you won't get forked by a white knight
if one of your pieces on one side and
the king's on the other side if your
pieces are too close together you'll get
forked you'll get double attacked
so that's a good strategy with knights
on the board
keep your pieces far away from your king
when you're facing the knights okay
yeah you have a look at the with those
circuits that the knights will travel on
and try to keep your peace as far away
as possible from that and
anish still has a threat of pushing his
a pawn alice she's gonna get marching
and
again it's very unpleasant for richard
to defend and he gives a check king
steps back
and how i mean presumably he just wants
to
i mean i'm trying to think of ways
to try to give up a night
and at the same time
win
the black f for pawn that's not possible
so he gives check yep makes sense what
in doubt give some checks and uh at some
point you'll write your anchor
white will try and get rid of black's
pawns at any cost even at the cost of
some knights
so uh
yeah the night attacking the white uh
attacking the black bishop right now the
bishop retreats very far away but
white's knight's actually very well
centralized right now
you can imagine the white king stepping
forward
yeah he's going to save this game
rapport definitely
black's pieces are just too passive the
black king the black bishop they're just
on bad squares and right now this check
is actually very annoying white central
pawn looks very dangerous all of a
sudden
yeah things suddenly just like that
they've they've turned black's king's
been forced from the white half all the
way back to the background yeah
and uh okay i i like your idea of just
stepping forward with the white king
also if he wants to get really ambitious
maybe he can even start thinking about
pushing his own pawns
and he has extra time
in the bank to think about things
i uh what are you going to go for king
forward yeah when doubt just advance
your king get rid of black spawns easy
draw but knowing rapport yeah he wants
to win this game
he's sensing a bit of weakness maybe in
anishikiri
but it's a bit risky what he's done he
said he's won one of blackspawn's but
he's completely abandoned this guy alice
the a pawn
it's three squares away from promotion
and the white knights are very very far
away
so he's playing with fire here report
i said he wants to uh he wanted to win
but is he trying to find a way to lose
suddenly
both sides at one minute rapport for the
first time in this game is lower on the
clock
okay he gives another check
and how is he getting his knights back
he needs to really hurry now that black
pawn is so close
and some of the squares the white
knights want to use to retreat they are
covered
i guess he has to use the uh
f4 knight and uh plank it on the b4
square or the c1 square
and that way he has
the past alice the a pawn under control
and he gives a check
um richard the problem with him is we
can never guess his moves
he's always going to do what we least
expect to always what uh the opponent
least expects
and right now where is gary gonna try
and hide the black king
okay it goes back where it came from oh
this is the second time we've seen this
position and
third time it's a draw
it is a draw richard reporter underneath
geary what are two of the favorites